Os lo podéis imaginar: estáis en
un bar y, sabes, o en una discoteca,
todo eso, y te pones a hablar y al rato,
pues, sale en la conversación
"¿y tú en qué trabajas?"
Y como piensas que tu trabajo es
interesante, le dices "Soy matemático".
(Risas)
Cuando esa conversación
sigue, invariablemente
en algún momento aparece
una de estas 2 frases:
A) "Yo es que era fatal con las
matemáticas, pero no era culpa mía,
es que el profesor
era horroroso". (Risas)
Y B) "¿Pero eso de las matemáticas
para qué sirve?" (Risas)
Me ocuparé del caso B.
(Risas)
Cuando alguien te pregunta para
qué sirven las matemáticas,
no te está preguntando por aplicaciones
de las ciencias matemáticas.
Te está preguntando:
"¿Y yo por qué tuve que estudiar
esa mierda que no volví
a usar nunca?" (Risas)
Es lo que te está preguntando realmente.
Ante esto, cuando a un
matemático le preguntan
para qué sirven las matemáticas,
los matemáticos nos dividimos en grupos.
Un 54,51 % de los matemáticos
toma una postura al ataque,
y un 44,77 % de los matemáticos
toma una postura a la defensiva.
Hay un 0,8 %, raro,
entre los que me incluyo.
¿Qué son los del ataque?
Los del ataque son matemáticos
que te dicen que esa pregunta
no tiene sentido, porque las matemáticas
tienen un sentido propio en sí mismas,
son un edificio bellísimo que tiene
una lógica propia que se construye
y que no hace falta que uno esté siempre
mirando las posibles aplicaciones.
¿Para qué sirve la poesía?
¿Para qué sirve el amor?
¿Para qué sirve la vida misma?
¿Qué pregunta es esa? (Risas)
Hardy, por ejemplo, es un
exponente de este ataque.
Y los que están a la
defensiva te dicen que
aunque no te des cuenta, cariño, las
matemáticas están detrás de todo. (Risas)
Estos siempre nombran, siempre,
nombran los puentes y las computadoras.
Si no sabes matemática
se te cae el puente. (Risas)
Realmente las computadoras
son todo matemáticas.
Ahora a estos les ha dado también
por decirte que detrás
de la seguridad informática y las tarjetas
de crédito están los números primos.
Estas son las respuestas que te va a dar
tu profe de matemática si le preguntas.
Es de los de la defensiva.
Vale, pero ¿y quién lleva razón?
¿Los que dicen que las matemáticas
no tienen por qué servir para nada,
o los que dicen que realmente
está detrás de todo?
Realmente tienen razón los dos.
Pero os he dicho que yo era de ese
0,8 % raro que dice otra cosa, ¿verdad?
Así que, vale, preguntadme
para qué sirven las matemáticas.
(El público pregunta)
¡Vale! Un 76,34 % de la gente
ha preguntado, hay un 23,41 %
que se ha callado, y un 0,8 %
que yo no sé lo que están haciendo esos.
Bueno, querido 76,31%, las matemáticas
es verdad que no tienen
por qué servir para nada, es verdad
que son un edificio precioso,
un edificio lógico, probablemente
uno de los mayores esfuerzos colectivos
que el ser humano ha hecho
a lo largo de la historia.
Pero también es verdad que allá donde
los científicos, donde los técnicos,
andan buscando teorías matemáticas,
modelos que les permitan avanzar,
ahí están, en el edificio de
las matemáticas, que lo permean todo.
Es verdad que tenemos que ir
algo más al fondo,
vamos a ver qué hay detrás de la ciencia.
La ciencia funciona por intuición,
por creatividad, y las matemáticas
doman la intuición y doman la creatividad.
A casi todo el mundo que no lo ha oído
antes le sorprende que si uno cogiera
una hoja de papel de 0,1 mm de grosor,
esas que utilizamos normalmente,
lo suficientemente grande,
y la pudiera doblar 50 veces,
el grosor de ese montón ocuparía
la distancia de la Tierra al Sol.
Tu intuición te dice: "Eso es imposible".
Echa las cuentas y verás que sí.
Para eso sirven las matemáticas.
Es verdad que la ciencia, toda la ciencia,
solamente tiene sentido
porque nos hace comprender mejor
el mundo este hermoso en el que estamos.
Y porque nos hace, nos ayuda
a sortear las trampas
del mundo este doloroso
en el que estamos.
Hay ciencias que tocan
esa aplicación con la mano.
La ciencia oncológica, por ejemplo.
Y hay otras que la miramos
desde lejos, con envidia a veces,
pero sabiendo que somos su soporte.
Todas las ciencias básicas
son el soporte de aquellas,
y entre ellas las matemáticas.
Todo lo que hace a la ciencia
ser ciencia es el rigor de la matemática.
Y ese rigor les viene porque
sus resultados son eternos.
Seguramente han dicho,
o os han dicho alguna vez,
que un diamante es
para siempre, ¿verdad?
¡Depende lo que uno
entienda por siempre!
¡Un teorema, eso sí
que es para siempre! (Risas)
El teorema de Pitágoras,
eso es verdad
aunque se haya muerto Pitágoras,
te lo digo yo. (Risas)
Aunque se hunda el mundo el teorema
de Pitágoras seguiría siendo verdad.
Allá donde se junten un par de catetos
y una buena hipotenusa (Risas)
el teorema de Pitágoras
funciona a tope, a tope.
(Aplausos)
Bueno, los matemáticos nos
dedicamos a hacer teoremas.
Verdades eternas. Pero no siempre
es tan fácil saber qué es
una verdad eterna, un teorema,
y qué es una mera conjetura.
Hace falta una demostración.
Por ejemplo: imaginaos que tengo aquí
un campo grande, enorme, infinito.
Lo quiero cubrir con piezas iguales,
sin dejar huecos.
Podría usar cuadrados, ¿verdad?
Podría usar triángulos.
Círculos no, que dejan huequitos.
¿Cuál es la mejor pieza que puedo usar?
La que para cubrir la misma superficie
tiene un borde más pequeño.
Pappus de Alejandría, en el año 300
dijo que lo mejor era usar hexágonos,
como hacen las abejas.
¡Pero no lo demostró!
El tío dijo "¡hexágonos, uh, lo peta,
venga, hexágonos, dámelo!"
No lo demostró, se quedó en una
conjetura, dijo "¡Hexágonos!"
El mundo, como sabéis, se dividió
entre pappistas y anti-pappistas,
hasta que 1700 años después,
1700 años después,
en 1999 Thomas Hales
demostró que Pappus
y las abejas llevaban razón,
que lo mejor es usar hexágonos.
Y eso se convirtió en un teorema,
el teorema del panal,
que va a ser verdad para
siempre, siempre jamás,
más que cualquier diamante que tengas.
(Risas)
¿Pero qué pasa si vamos a 3 dimensiones?
Si quiero llenar el espacio,
con piezas iguales, sin dejar huecos,
puedo usar cubos, ¿verdad?
Esferas no, que dejan huequitos. (Risas)
¿Cuál es la mejor pieza
que puedo usar?
Lord Kelvin, el de los grados Kelvin
y todo eso, ese dijo
que lo mejor era usar
un octaedro truncado (Risas)
que como todos sabéis (Risas)
¡Es esto de aquí! (Aplausos)
¡Vamos! ¿Quién no tiene
un octaedro truncado en casa? (Risas)
Aunque sea de plástico. Nene, trae
el octaedro truncado, que vienen visitas.
¡Todo el mundo tiene! (Risas)
Pero Kelvin no lo demostró.
Se quedó en una conjetura,
la conjetura de Kelvin.
El mundo como sabéis, se dividió
entre kelvinistas y anti-kelvinistas
(Risas)
hasta que ciento y pico años después,
ciento y pico años después,
alguien encontró una estructura mejor.
Weaire y Phelan, Weaire y Phelan
encontraron esta cosita de aquí,
(Risas) esta estructura a la que pusieron
el imaginativo nombre de
estructura de Weaire y Phelan. (Risas)
Parece una cosa rara
pero no es tan rara,
también está presente en la naturaleza.
Es muy curioso que esta estructura,
por sus propiedades geométricas,
se utilizó para construir
el edificio de la natación
en los Juegos Olímpicos de Pekín.
Allá Michael Phelps ganó
8 medallas de oro, se convirtió
en el mejor nadador de todos los tiempos.
Bueno, de todos los tiempos
hasta que salga otro mejor, ¿no?
Cómo le pasa a la estructura
de Weaire y Phelan,
es la mejor hasta que salga otra mejor.
Pero cuidado, porque esta sí
que tiene la oportunidad,
de que aunque pasen ciento y pico años,
aunque sea dentro de 1700 años,
alguien demuestra que esta
es la mejor pieza posible.
Y entonces será un teorema,
una verdad para siempre, siempre jamás.
Más que cualquier diamante.
Así que, bueno, si queréis decirle
a alguien que le queréis para siempre
(Risas)
le podéis regalar un diamante,
pero si le queréis decir
que le queréis para siempre, siempre,
¡regaladle un teorema!
(Risas)
Eso sí, quieto, lo tendréis que demostrar,
que vuestro amor no se quede en conjetura.
(Aplausos)